so over the past few days there has been
seemingly out of nowhere a full court
press by some on the right to
rehabilitate Bud Light and to convince
conservatives to drop the boycott of the
company if you consider yourself a
patriot right you're a
patriot you should be drinking gallons
of Bud Light believe me when I tell you
wait wait wait I should be boycot I
should be boycotting Bud Light G gallons
of Bud Light you should have budlight
drums stacked up in your garage and
drinking it right out of the keg we
actually made the woke company feel the
pain we imposed our will in a way that
conservatives have never been able to do
ever so we'd have to have a very
compelling strategic reason to end this
one single successful boycott campaign
ever we would have to have extracted
some kind of major concession